okay hello everyone my name is Jennifer
leak and I'm a fellow at the Whitehead
Institute for biomedical research thank
you very much for joining me to my talk
about genome hacking so what I'm going
to talk today is going to discuss the
results of our recent study that we
showed how you can identify anonymous
whole genome sequencing data using
basically internet searches and my lab
at the white hood Institute in human
genetics is interested in a range of
topics and human genetics and we
published two papers about the genetic
basis of two devastating disorders one
is a hereditary [ __ ] paralysis and
the other one is super syndrome and they
would like to emphasize the point that
we were not able to publish and to
identify these two genes in these
disorders without people sharing data
about their own genome healthy people
share their own data and we can use the
these datasets to exclude mutations that
are not positive in these two studies so
i would like to start my talk by
emphasizing the point that public data
sharing is highly important but we also
need to understand the privacy
expectations and autotune the privacy
expectations of participants in these
studies if we want to have a long-term
sustainable endeavor now the interest in
a walking on these topics goes to the
day that I was an undergrad student and
I worked as a little ego one slide deck
so I was
what you just saw because the movie was
played prematurely basically and I
walked as a security in a security
company and mr. him services for banks
credit a credit card companies to
checked our buses of their systems so
what we used to do is to go to these
companies and to try to do penetration
tests and the movie that adjust that
we'll just play on the screen it was
basically a penetration test in one of
the banks that I walked but I think it
was if we can maybe play it again I can
I can explain what what we saw over
there
just using my own cell phone and I'm can
I can manipulate their the door in this
Bank and enter to the IT department
anyhow let's maybe skip to the next
slide and let me talk about privacy in
genomics in self privacy in and said how
to hack into a bank so I cannot see my
slides for some reason just for a moment
okay how about you can see my style at
least ok so the starting point of this
presentation about the privacy of whole
genome sequencing data is a study is
easy is a manuscript published about a
year ago by the NCI think tank and in
this manuscript they said that all omics
data are theoretically identifiable but
you really need a considerable effort
and cost to be able to identify
individuals a in this data set and they
concluded that the risk is highly remote
and this is a starting point of our
study we wanted to challenge it to see
basically the same the same way that we
did penetration tests in the bank to
check empirically the robust sense of
their system we wanted to empirically
check this statement over here so about
a decade ago it has been recognized
there is cost segregation between Y
chromosome and surnames I cannot control
my slides there sorry about that
I'm just trying to fix the animation in
my slide because I cannot move through
for my slide I really sorry about this
technical difficulty let's try okay here
here we go so here we have a so as I
Tony about a decade ago though it has
been recognized that there is cost
segregation between Y chromosome and
surname for instance here we have the
Smith family so if this family has a son
then the father will give the Sun his Y
chromosome and also his surname now in
most Western societies now if this son
is getting married he will give an
oscillator son he will give his son his
Y chromosome and also his surname and
this process will continue forward and
will only break up by mutation events
non-pertinent events and explicit
surname conversions now regression ille
genealogy companies a also so that they
can they can use this process basically
to connect between patrilineal relatives
so today there are multiple companies
that offer services in which they will
send you a swab to check a DNA 8222
simple dinner in your jig you put this
swab in a mail envelope and send it to
the company with 200 bucks very
important and then the company will
genotype short tandem repeats STRs on
your Y chromosome ill and will upload
the information to a website so for
instance here the information can go to
y search org now during my presentation
I
called you since you have also internet
connection to go to this website and to
see that they exist and that to see how
they look like and what you can do with
them and what you see over here are my
own test results basically and the
reason that people do this genetic test
is that this way they can connect with
their patrol lineal relatives that they
don't know just based on genetic matches
it's a lot of fun right and as I said
this on my own a test results online so
about seven years ago there was a very
interesting article in The Washington
Post describing a child that was
conceived by anonymous sperm donation
and this child after he grew up a scent
is dn8 one of these recreational
genealogy companies the dirt at the Y
chromosome and they sending a identified
in their databases two hits of
individuals with the same surname is two
individuals has the same surname now we
didn't know what was the surname of his
own father but he concluded that maybe
this is a sternum of his father's in see
he has dis matches from on his Y
chromosome he also knew what was the
exact birthdate of his father and day in
the hospital so we went to a private
detectives begin with all these pieces
of information the surname the birth of
date and in the hospital and they were
able to find one record in this hospital
that much exactly to this description
equal to the person in the record and
they indeed this person donated sperm so
he was able to connect with his
biological father and we thought okay is
this an incident so you know it was in
the newspaper this is something that
happens one in a million one in a
thousand one in one we really wanted to
do a systematic study to characterize
this process and to see if it risks
personal genomes so the questions can be
covered correct can we recover the
identity of anonymous sequencing data
sets using these public resources
if we can go to the y chromosome submit
information to this resources and then
infer the surname of the of the
individuals and then really to get a
lead and to identify the people that
donated their DNA so we decided to focus
on two databases one is SMG F dot org
and the other one is why cept org and
together these databases have more than
135,000 y-str surname record and is that
is accessible also to you you can as I
said before you have an internet
connection you can go to these databases
and see that you can search the data so
the first thing was we wanted to see if
the databases reflect the distribution
of the officer names in the US
population so we compared the prevalence
of the different surnames in the u.s.
population based on the census data we
see it here on the x axis versus the
number of records for the same surname
in the database on the y axis and we
found that there is a significant
correlation between the two in fact
sixty-eight percent of the u.s.
population of the surnames Obama so
there is a sixty-eight percent chance of
settling a random individual from the US
population and that the surname of this
individual will be in the database so we
don't have all the surnames in the
database but we have a significant
amount of them and for the ones that we
do have in the database they really
reflect the distribution of the US
population smell we wanted empirically
to check what is the probability to
recover a surname of a male in the u.s.
population okay so we took a wise TR of
real people from the US population
we queried these two databases SMG fny
search and then we had some sort of an
algorithm to infer the most likely
surname which I will not go to the
technical details but it's available on
the paper that we published and then we
infer the surname from the from the wire
steel markers and we checked is this the
right surname or not and we repeated
this process more than 900 times so more
than 900 individuals in this process and
what we found was oops they go one side
further so first here is what what you
see basically when we do this process
this is the number of successes that we
have is function of generations so when
we do the process we can use the white
chromosome is a molecular clock to
estimate the number of generation that
passed between the y-str of the person
that we don't know the surname and the
wise dr's of the best hit we can see how
much time elapsed between these two
individuals and based on that get the
confidence if these two individuals are
closely related let's say are only 10
generations apart with high probability
that they do share the same surname so
we can increase our confidence if they
are distant individuals let's say that
they are related only 50 generations ago
but 50 generations ago if the every
generation is 25 years it means that
these two people are related have a
common ancestor that lived thousand
years ago the likelihood that they have
to serve the same surname is is
extremely low because they really share
very ancient ancestor before even the
advent of the surname system in Western
societies so what we see over here that
on average if we find an exact match of
the same surname the two individual the
twin dividuals live ten generations ago
in some very small number of cases but
very interesting we found spelling
variants of the same surname for
instance I show you here
airlink my last 7 m can be spelled by
two different ways with an agent without
so we saw that people will be spending
value and they tend to share a common
ancestor bit a bit older common ancestor
and when you have completely wrong a
wrong match we the team RCA live 24 or
or more generations ago so you can use
this process ready to build a to
fine-tune our signal and to zoom in on
the matches that we think that are
correct so what we found was that if we
a take if we allow for five percent
wrong surnames in our analysis then with
this rate the expectation for us
Caucasian males from mid and upper class
is twelve percent successful recoveries
let me restate that so in this process
week we can tune the confidence score of
our seven recovery I can be very
permissive and then get ready Get
Married get a lot of matches to people
but most of the time these matches will
be very old very old team LCA and will
not have these people will not have the
same surname or I can be very
restrictive in my joining and only to
allow to say that the two people share
the same surname only if the team RCA is
very recent but then I will have less
and would have less less matches so
basically we killed it that will get
five percent wrong recoveries and with
that rate we can recover successfully we
get correct matches for twelve percent
of the u.s. population okay so we have
twelve percent of the u.s. we can
recover the surnames of twelve percent
of the u.s. population with [ __ ] asian
ancestry for middle and upper class but
maybe all the time we just get surnames
that our extremely a
prevalent in population such as Smith
Johnson Jackson there are millions of
people in the US that will have the same
surname right so even if I can recover
the surnames maybe I just I will not get
enough information that i can zoom in
and get individual because a certain is
so prevalent so we can say that
empirically and what we found is in this
empirical test with the nine hundred
individuals was that in most cases the
surnames that we recover are relatively
rare in most cases the serving
corresponds to one in four thousand
people so it means that if I know the
surname I can go from a group of 150
million males in the u.s. to only about
forty thousand males just by knowing the
surname on average okay so we have
40,000 miles but now the question is can
i zoom in to a specific individual in
these forty thousand males so okay so so
no recovery even if it's successful can
only give me forty thousand individuals
I really want one the one that
participated in the genomic study how
can we do that so we am we fought about
the following scenario let's assume that
we didn't only recover the serum of the
individual but also we have demographic
information about this individual such
as the age and the state according to
the HIPAA Privacy Rule age and state are
not considered identifiers so in some
databases and i'm going to show you real
examples you expect to find the age of
the state of individuals that donated
their their genome so what would happen
if I have the H information the state
and I can recover the surname so we get
a scene
we conducted simulations using the
census data we took the edge
distribution of males let's say someone
that is 40 years old with the state
let's say Colorado and the surname let's
say Adams and then we asked how many
individuals in the US would match such a
profile Adams Colorado 40 years old we
conduct the simulation 100,000 times and
what we found was that age state and
surname this profile gives me less than
12 males in most of the cases so again
we start with 150 million males in the
US if I know the surname I can go to
40,000 individuals then if I add the age
of the state information i will go to 12
or less people in most cases now when
you have 12 people it's very easy to
know who is the individual that donated
the data first you can just call all 12
people and ask them did you did you
participate in a genetic study that will
be one option or any other other piece
of information that is posted with the
genome can really help you to identify
the individual for instance the pedigree
structure or other phenotypic
information so that when it becomes
struck table okay so so far I just
showed you and the things that are based
on on multiple pieces of evidence right
but let's now try to stitch everything
together so we decided to focus on craig
Venter let's see how it works we took
craig venter genome from NCBI without
added his genome and we profiled the
short tandem repeat eNOS on his genome
it's lobster this is a tool that we
published about a year ago in the genome
research and this tool allows you to
profile shot interprets in
high-throughput sequencing data so for
example we found that craig Venter has
17 repeats on the Y chromosome marker
called dys 458 then we went to why
search not all to the search mechanism
and at Lisa mean and we just inserted
for each marker that we found we just
inserted the number of repeats to the
search interface and we clicked search
on this web page and after a few seconds
we found that the top match the top
surname predicted by this database is
Venter now I told you that this is based
on publicly available resources so if
you want to replicate what I just did
you can go to the link but that is
posted on the screen right now bit ly
Craig underscore Venter underscore
haplotype underscore updated go to this
link it will redirect you to the y
search web page with all the markers
that we found on in the GM of craig
Venter just click search and see if you
can recover and see that venter is the
top match in there in the database so
basically what I just showed you was a
way I just show you how we can take
whole genome sequencing data often
individual and using just computational
tools and publicly available resources
we can get a surname of this individual
and also we verified that this DNA
doesn't belong to craig Venter it's
someone else's in his family that
donated the DNA but okay so we can get
the surname Venter from craig Venter
genome that can really zoom
and get craig venter through this
information let's see how it works so if
we know the state California and that
the craig venter was born be off of a
bath is 1946 and is also a male we can
go to public record a search engines
such as you search calm or people
finders calm and insert these four
pieces of information the surname that
we recovered the state the year of birth
and we just we can filter for only male
hits in these researches so we did this
process and what we found in us
search.com was we identified two
individuals that matched this
description Ventura California born were
born in 1946 and they were males one of
which was our friend quite render
himself so I just show you how we can
take whole genome sequencing data and
using only complication tools and
internet searches to zoom in from 150
million individuals to just two
individuals including craig Venter
himself okay but but you know what Eddie
craig Venter was just cheating right
because we know that this person is
craig Venter and we search for the same
person that that we know his identity
but I really want to show you is that we
can use this process to identify
anonymous personal genomes not just
people that we know so we focused on the
a/c you panel in the thousand genomes
project the CEO panel is composed from
participants from for mutant and we took
ten genomes from this panel and again we
just provide the why a short tunnel pits
in these genomes with lobster and then
we queried these two websites we
why STR markers and we got 87
predictions with Utah ancestry so this
is actually quite good right we are
looking for people in Utah and we got
certain predictions with people will do
the ancestry but did we get the right
individuals so we decided to focus first
on this family that I show you over here
this is a three generation family each
one of the individuals in this family
donated DNA data the founders of the
family the grandparents are part of the
thousand genomes but also the father the
mother and all the children donated
their DNA and our part of the hapmap
project and you can get their DNA it's
part of the of the Creole said
repository and there are many their
expression arrays that were done on this
family Jim tagging arrays and so on we
were using the thousand genomes data we
recovered the surname of the paternal
grandfather and the maternal grandfather
so we had two surnames and then we did
something very simple went to Google and
we just search we did a search very
similar to what I'll show you on the
slide we don't disclose the exact
details to respect the privacy of the
family but it's something extremely
similar to what what is on the screen
right now and the search in Google just
click search the top heat of the search
the first link in this google search was
an obituary that exactly matched the
description of this pedigree in the
creole etsell repository what do I mean
by that first the number of children in
this obituary was exactly the same to
the number of children in the
pedigree in the Creole a website the
birth order of males and females was
exactly the same now this is a big this
is a big family with multiple kids what
are the chances that each one of these
kids will be exactly the same by the
male and female every time I check
tossing a coin and we toss this call it
multiple times the surname of the Father
and obituary matched to the serum of the
paternal grandfather the maiden name of
the mother match to the surname of the
maternal grandfather and these two
surnames are quite rare in the
population and also we check the ages of
some of the people in this and in this
pedigree game and match it to the people
in the obituary and the ages were
exactly the same so what are the chances
that we found the wrong family and we
did a calculation and we estimate that
the chances of finding the wrong family
after scaling all households in United
States is 5 times 10 to the minus 9
extremely extremely small but you know
what maybe it was just beginner's luck I
just show you one family right let's see
if we can replicate this process and
indeed we can replicate it we identified
another family from this in from the
thousand genomes using the same
technique and another family all of
which are big families and the chances
that we've identified the wrong family
are quite low after scanning all house
on the United States now the individuals
at the black rectangles are the
individuals of which we had successful
cellular coverage so we had five
successful sir recoveries that we can go
back and find the family and we could
identify it so again this individuals
it's not just that the founders just the
grandparents donated their DNA but all
the entire family donated their DNA so
basically we could expose you could link
between DNA data sets
the coriolis a repository of about 50
people that because every time that we
identified we recover the surname and
identify one member in his family we
could identify all the other members and
by that expose the identities of all the
other people in the coryell website but
we had so much information at that point
that we could even infer the link
between the people that donated their
DNA to recreational genealogy and the
people that participated in the thousand
genomes project so the people the red
labels just shows the line of the lines
of people that donated their DNA to the
people that we identified and the arrows
shows the people that participated that
donated their DNA to recreational
genealogy I want to emphasize his point
because it's extremely important the
people that donated their DNA to
recreational genealogy are not the same
people that are part of the thousand
genomes we can use a knot we can use
foul relatives because of the
propagation of because of the
association of Y chromosome and surnames
for example in the pedigree in the
middle you can see on the on the
maternal side that the second cousin
once removed of the thousand genomes
participant he donated his DNA to
recreational genealogy and by doing so
he exposed the identity of his entire
family on the third pedigree that the
pedigree on the right you see the
grandchild that is not part of the off
of the Korean database donated his DNA
to recreational genealogy and by that he
exposed all the in the oles entire
family including his grandparents that
donated their DNA to research so here is
the thing that maybe not let's let's go
to the next slide
site over here let me summarize this
this part I'll show you a way how we can
in reach the privacy of individuals
there is no experimental work involved I
can just use computer resources to
profile the ysd us and to go and search
the internet databases so basically the
entry level is not as if you need to
have a lab where you need to have access
to two pcr or something that you just
need access needed a good computer and
access to the internet that information
that that we use to identify people
propagates via deep genealogical ties so
it means that if you decide to
participate in a study and your second
cousin once removed donated his DNA to
recreation genealogy if you're a male
there is a chance that we that someone
can identify you because of the the
weather the information propagates and
also show you that this the attack
completely relies on public resources
you you don't need any special access to
any database all the data is available
online and i gave you link so these
databases and i showed you evidence
based on testing close two thousand
wives their haplotypes to recover the
rate the probability of a surname united
states i showed you how we can identify
craig venter and that we can identify
close to 15 individuals that are part of
the queer database using this technique
so our study was published in science in
general and before the publication we
this is our visits its controversial
Sally right like you want to make sure
that you expose this vulnerability but
to do that in responsible way so before
the publication we went and we talked
with all the stakeholders that we can
think that are involved in the thousand
genomes
in this court in the thousand genomes so
we talked with the thousand genomes
steering committee with the NHGRI and
with the University of filter that
originally collected these centers and
we were trying you know did this and
received very a nice attention from from
the from the community in fact a natural
tutorial for this was a very a good way
to address a vulnerability in privacy
research also we based our we we
discussed our results with the NHGRI and
we hold on our publication until they
were ready to respond to this
vulnerability so what they did they
remove the ages from the Creole database
it doesn't completely prevent
identification but it raises the bar it
becomes harder to identify these people
and also i highly encourage you to read
their respect their perspective about
our study basically we hold on the
publication of our study until they
wrote their perspective so they can do
not rate they we will publish it back to
back with them to give the readers
really a integrative and comprehensive
overview of of of this vulnerability so
let's go back to today our starting
point so you know we said no the
starting point was that omics data are
theoretically identifiable but you need
this considerable effort and that the
risk is highly remote and what we showed
you that at least technically a this
risk is not highly remote and it's
feasible to identify subsets of genomes
that are out there using just public
resources okay so i have another part of
of my talk and this part is more of a
conversation how we should move forward
but before going to this part let me
maybe go to the QA and let's see maybe
there are some questions that i can
address and then we can we can move to
the second part which is it's basically
more complicate slides to facilitate the
conversation in
to how to move oil but before maybe I do
that let me just I want to acknowledge
the people that were involved in this
study so most of the study was done by
Melissa gem week she's a second-year
Harvard MIT student in my lab very
talented student we're also collaborated
as part of this study with Annie Maguire
in Baylor and the vid colon and run
halperin a from Tel Aviv University so
now I will go here and let's see the Q&A
let's see if I can um okay so we have I
hope that I pronounce the name correctly
munching Lee he or she asks what is the
economical motivation behind these
companies which commercialize such
databases and how is the process of
prevention of bridging of privacy being
regulated very very two very good
questions that we let them ask here so
the canonical motivation in these
databases is that people are interested
in their genealogy and they are
interested in finding their relatives
and this is the reason why these
companies offer these tests now they
they don't restrict the access some
companies don't restrict access to their
databases because they want to to have
other people from other companies to go
to the database and also donate the data
this way they can really appeal it more
data and connect with more and more
people so they also allow other people
to search even if you didn't pay to
participate in the test you can just go
with the markers that you are from a
different company and then search for
the results and this way they can get
more more traffic and more matches in
their databases using bye bye bye bye
basically putting these databases
available now the other question was how
is the process basically if you can
regulate these databases right so
there are two answers for this question
the first answer that it's extremely how
to regulate anything on the internet
right people they own their own genome
they can publish their own genome right
we cannot tell people don't publish your
own genome and once these databases are
set people it is extremely hard to to
say that you are not allowed to publish
something about yourself online right
the second answer for this question is
that even if right now there will be
some regulation and somehow this
databases will be shut down where the
information is already scattered online
so there are other databases that
replicate that mirror the main database
and are in other places outside of the
US someone database is actually in
Russia quite big database I think it
makes to me how to develop a legal
framework that will allow the regulation
or authorized restrict access to this
data bases and what we have right now is
this complex ecosystem right that and we
have real question genealogy on one side
we we don't want to have this industry
this is a wonderful industry as i said i
participated in some of the tests and
also we have this scientific quite
significant data that we collect and we
want to share whole want to share as
many germs as possible we just need to
aim to think how this in this ecology
how the to this it is ecosystem how
these two activities can live together
okay we have another question from a
Fiona Nielsen and she asks the study you
showed was based on repeat regions do
you have some comments on the risk of
identification from sleeps alone very
good question so on the white so let's
let's separate we have the snips on the
Y chromosome and asleep on the outer
zone so right now you need a lot of
slips on the Y chromosome to really get
to the right so named because snakes on
the Y chromosome you take much
slower than this STRs and there are
there are some community efforts that
started to collect surnames and why
sleeps and I in the manuscript if you go
to the discussion part of the manuscript
you recite one of these resources so you
can check it if there's only a few
thousand a why sleeps and surnames so
it's not really developed but other
companies we know that a family tree DNA
and other companies are currently enter
to the world of high-throughput
sequencing so maybe we're going to see
more studies of slips and surnames so
maybe this will be this risk will be a
will emerge in the future now the other
part what about the risk of identifying
people from the autosomal swings so the
easiest technique to identify someone
for me from autosomal snips is just to
compare his DNA right like basically to
take 30 snips on the autozone and see if
these 30 snips match the the individual
in the database there are other
techniques that involve familial
searching using slips on the autozone
there are some papers more theoretical
papers about it but I'm not I don't talk
any study that used publicly available
resources that you can take autosomal
snips and use them to search a relatives
of people although I think that there
are at least few resources that allow
you to do that but there are no studies
actually check that empirically so I
don't know what what is the risk I
cannot quantify this this risk and
photos all Muslims okay please go in
submit more questions if you ever will
just basically go through the next
slides how we can move forward okay so
there are three techniques right that we
can consider in fact all these
techniques are already this kind of like
a pointed out in there in the two
questions that I addressed so let me go
over this and six techniques that we can
maybe mitigate the
risk using these techniques and I what
I'm going to show you if in fact I'm not
good talk about secure computing I'm
just going to talk about the five a
first five techniques and and so one
option is basically we can just mask the
wires your mother is right you can just
basically every time but there is why is
their marketing the genome we can just
discard the Rings and not publish them
so this is the advantage of this
technique that it's it's easy it's fast
there is almost no margin on data usage
because not many people are interested
in studying yst ours but the
disadvantages is basing the decision not
a long-term solution as Fiona just in a
question just what about the snips on
the Y chromosome so there is a
possibility that these snips can still
be used either to search genetic data
bases all that we can infer the why STRs
we can impute the wires using the slips
and we discuss this process in the paper
so basically you can circumvent the
masking just by looking at the snips and
and placing back the wise TRS so when I
am asking is not a good technique
another option is if we just and
basically what if we take the entire
white chromosome and just toss this Y
chromosome away right this for sure will
eliminate the possibility for certain
influence the disadvantages is first
very sub-community push back so the
director of the White at institute where
I walk is David page and is highly
interested in the in the Y chromosome
and I don't think that people that are
interested in Y chromosome are going to
like this this option but you know
another other disadvantages but the main
one is this sustainable because okay we
just in this study we showed the
limitation of
or the vulnerability of inferring
surnames from the Y chromosome maybe
tomorrow there will be another study
using autosomal snips that will allow
you to infer a different types of
relationships and use that to triangle
individual if we start this process of
masking areas in the genome I don't
think it's going to be sustainable and I
don't think we should address challenges
by masking areas and chopping the
genomes into pieces okay another option
that was part of the of the Q&A was
maybe we should just you know shut down
these genealogical data bases and the
you know this will eliminate the this
problem of Sullivan friends there will
be no burden on the genomics community
right if we shut down these databases we
as a human geneticist we need to do
nothing right we don't need to master
data there is no problem the
disadvantages as I said is that fresh
this is internet censorship it's legal
it'd be very hard to do that it also
nearly impossible to really remove all
the entries from the internet because
there are so many website here we just
least some of the websites that pull
twice the hours and surnames information
it will be almost impossible to remove
all these websites phone from the
internet and to make sure that there are
no mirrors and they're not Google Cashin
and so on okay another option is not
them the regular wear a bra suspect
right the regular thing that we can do
just access control let's take the
entire genome and put it behind a lock
and we're going to give the kids took
the key only two people that we trust so
this will eliminate you know any any
privacy problem in general it's not very
technically challenging to do something
like that it's quite easy but there are
the problems that we need to consider
and i started this stock by showing you
two studies that we conducted just in my
group
that we identified the genetic basis of
devastating disorders using healthy
people that donated the genome we will
not we will not be able to do that
without these people that donated their
genome so so access control is a valid
option technically the question if we
really want to do that another option
that I really like and I advocate but
again it's itself it's personal taste
right is that we will continue to do
data sharing but we will tell our
participants about the risks in in in
whole genome sequencing will tell her
that there might be identified but at
the same time we also tell them about
the benefits of participating in whole
genome sequencing studies how much it
cultivates to society how much it
contributes to people that are affected
by devastating disorders and by doing so
by tended the benefits and the risks the
hope is to get enough people that it
will participate in the studies and and
the 22 that we can kill their
expectations about piracy and I think
one of the and leaders in this school of
thought is Joel church and his personal
journals project that is exactly what
they do right they give people more than
20 pages of informed consent and after
the week the informed consent they need
to pass a test we did they tell me know
that the test includes all day that they
understand really the risks the privacy
risk in the whole genome sequencing and
so on and only then they can participate
in genetic study in the study of course
the disadvantage here is that some
people might decide not to participate
in the study and we're going to reduce
the hour a prospective data participant
that we can we can recruit to a
to a genomic studies and another thing
that many want to consider is to add
some legislation that will disallow
people to identify using genetic
information but the disadvantage over
here of course is that the distillation
is is hard it's not something that will
happen and tomorrow okay so basically I
finish my presentation and there is
another question and the question is by
letting and he asks can we apply this Y
chromosome system to the night Patrick
andreea and are there any privacy
problems in mitochondria databases a
similar today why str sternum studies
this is a great question so first people
also share mitochondria and you can go
to my toe search dog and so and see that
people people should share this
information now with the mitochondria
this serum doesn't properly like I'm not
aware of any identifiers that propagates
Wilda mitochondria because most in most
Western societies a certain propagates
from from the father side from the
mother side and it's hard to find any
identifiers it is that I can think of
that that goes this way in addition the
mitochondria doesn't have the same
revealing power is the Y chromosome it's
much smaller and you cannot get the same
resolution as with the Y chromosome so
it's hard to stratify between 20 vidual
that share a recent common ancestor
versus to individual the chair a very
old common ancestor so it's less
revealing so even if if there was some
identifiers it was how to tell it was
how to extract this identifier
accurately the same way that we do with
the Y chromosome okay so i will refer to
the website the bar conference live com
cme if you want to obtain credit and i
would like to thank you for for being in
this conference and also to apologize
for this technical difficulties at the
beginning
and thank you very much